no one thinks joe biden is particularly
with it
first we had president trump calling him
sleepy joe right then we had
conservatives generally raising
questions about biden's cognitive
decline then even you'd get the
occasional leak from a democrat
acknowledging it
but now you know things are really bad
when joe biden's own current secretary
of state
refuses to answer on national television
whether or not the president knows
what's going on
does the president not know what's going
on
this is an incredibly
emotional time
for for many of us
and including allies and partners who've
been shoulder to shoulder with us in
afghanistan for 20 years uh at high cost
themselves as well as to us they stood
with us after 9 11. invoked article 5 of
nato for the first time an attack on one
is an attack on all certainly
respectfully that that look i'm not i'm
not questioning whether or not the
allies have a right to complain i'm not
questioning whether or not al qaeda has
a presence the president said al-qaeda
is gone it's not gone the president said
he's not heard any criticism
from the allies there's been a lot of
criticism from the allies words matter
and the words of the president
matter most
does the president know what's going on
well you see chris it's an emotional
time i had an omelette for breakfast
today
my middle name is phillip i how many
things can i say to avoid answering this
question
wouldn't it wouldn't be that hard to say
yes he does know what's going on if he
actually knew what was going on
as biden bumbles the rest of america is
catching on to what conservatives have
known for years namely that joe biden is
completely incompetent in many ways that
was the whole point of nominating biden
biden is just nothing as i said during
the campaign repeatedly he's just an
empty suit he's just an avatar for the
liberal establishment a return to
normalcy which is exactly what our
ruling class said that they wanted
what's troubling right now for the
ruling class is that huge swaths of the
american people are beginning to realize
that the liberal establishment isn't all
that competent either i'm michael
knowles the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment friday is from timothy brinson
who says our founding fathers are
rolling in their graves
wishing that they hadn't voted for joe
biden i know i'm sure they're very upset
and they're going to be even more
frustrated when they vote for gavin
newsom in the recall election in
california it's just that's just the way
elections work these days if you want to
protect yourself
from all sorts of things
some of them underground some of them
above ground i would recommend you check
out american home shield i was woken up
the other night at about four in the
morning i was woken up by my dear wife
usually this is because my cute little
baby is screaming and she just wants a
little moral support with her but that
was not what was going on it was because
one of my pipes was screaming we had a
little bit of a leak going on outside it
was just such a hassle you think oh no
these some household breakdown
inevitably this is going to cost me a
thousand dollars it's just that i think
that is just anything it's like a light
bulb goes out and if you can't fix it
yourself somehow it's a thousand dollars
that's why i love american home shield
american home shield helps cover the
costs to repair and replace things like
your ac
or your fridge maybe you've got problems
with some plumbing maybe you've got
problems with hvac systems they've got
it american home shield members get
terrific coverage right now to celebrate
50 years of providing homeowners peace
of mind you can take 50 off their most
comprehensive plans ever that is ahs.com
knowles head on over there save 50 bucks
go to
ahs.com for 50 off any plan service fees
limitations and exclusions apply c plan
for details american home shield be sure
with the shield
is the president competent does the
president know what's going on well you
know
it's difficult and when you bring that
up it's
no he doesn't he obviously doesn't now
they're trying to play catch-up so
there's a report out that the biden
administration is trying to
reclaim or really just destroy the
military equipment that they left in
afghanistan so you remember there's a
lot of military equipment
billions and billions of dollars of
military equipment in afghanistan that
everyone just abandoned some of it was
given to the afghan army which collapsed
within days some of it was given to the
american troops who were told to get out
of dodge so there's just all this
equipment and guess who's taking the
equipment
the taliban so now we've spent a
taxpayer expense hundreds of billions of
dollars on military equipment that is
going
ostensibly to our enemy now i know the
biden administration is trying to cut a
deal with the taliban but they don't
seem to be particularly friendly right
now so now the biden administration is
considering going in and destroying that
equipment
maybe that's a good idea maybe that's
not a good idea
the one thing i think we can all agree
on even the most ardent joe biden
supporter whoever that may be
is that
maybe they should have thought about
this huh maybe they should have either
taken the equipment or destroyed the
equipment before they left
maybe anyone should have given this even
two seconds thought but they did we've
been in afghanistan for 20 years we've
been talking about getting out of
afghanistan for what 15 years now
then we went back in because obama
wanted a good war when he made the iraq
war the bad war but then
joe biden campaigned on getting out of
afghanistan donald trump campaigned on
getting out of afghanistan we've been
ready to do this for some time and yet
they say oops maybe we shouldn't have
left hundreds of billions of dollars
worth of military equipment either
there's some really nefarious
uh other motive here or this is just
gross incompetence
and
the thing about the liberal
establishment is they come in they take
away democratic choice they take away
our civil rights they upend standards in
society they upend the way that we live
our lives here but the promise that they
make
is
your life's going to be more efficient
it's going to be better this is when the
world economic forum says you're not
going to own anything in the future but
you're going to be really happy
it seems like a ghastly future but maybe
some people will go along with it if
they can actually deliver the happiness
if they can actually deliver the
efficiency if they can actually deliver
the competency but they can't
the whole point about trump was yeah
trump's giving you some things you like
politically but he's just he's so wild
he's it's so abnormal and extraordinary
right now elect us and it'll go back to
normal and will at least be competent at
running the government well you gotta at
least deliver that and and that's that's
something that they are not doing so now
axios is reporting they might go in and
destroy the equipment the problem is
though according to axios quote they
fear that such a move could provoke the
taliban at a time where the us is
focusing on evacuating people from
afghanistan so we we allegedly have
something like 15 000 americans there
again you think they would have given
this a moment's thought before they gave
up the air base
gave up their embassy and retreated to
to kabul airport but they've got to get
these people out
if they go in and start strikes on the
taliban
why things might not turn out very well
for the people that they're supposed to
get out so the taliban is an extremely
strong position
the united states is in an extremely
weak position and
what's driving me craziest i guess
watching these images
is finding out how good the taliban is
at trolling
the taliban they've been around for a
long time they're these arch islamic
fundamentalists but apparently they're
really internet savvy they're really
good at trolling all right it's really
awful to see this as an american they
just posted a photo
of them wearing american military
equipment very expensive nice american
military equipment hoisting the taliban
flag
recreating the image from iwo jima
and they know exactly what they're doing
and they're posting it now
all over
all over the internet they po they've
been posting memes you know there's a
meme it's the chad meme of
it's hard to explain a meme on air but
it's of you know sort of wimpy liberal
guys you know complaining about
something that they're doing and then
the sort of chad strong tough guy saying
yes and then
it's and it's got all of these various
internet characters so either they've
got a great pr consultant or some
members of the taliban actually are
following american pop culture pretty
closely you remember the the press
conference they gave it was one of the
greatest trolling
performances i've seen in my lifetime
you've got these these warlords from
this backwater this god forsaken land
and they come up with their
their
theological theocratic views that have
not changed even in the slightest for
about 1400 years and they're sitting
there ask being asked about free speech
and they say oh well maybe you should
ask the west about facebook because they
doesn't seem like the west cares much
about free speech
they're asked about the role of women in
their government they said oh don't
worry we'll be very inclusive
we'll be very diverse and inclusive
within the boundaries of sharia law
which is to say obviously not at all are
they going to model their government
after the west
but they know the language of the west
they know the idiosyncrasies of the west
they know how the west is going to react
going back to the very beginning of the
afghanistan war
they said the west has the watches
but the taliban's got the time
right we're just going to wait you out
we know that you're not going to want to
stay here for 100 years no one wants to
stay in afghanistan for 100 years so
you're going to get tired your
democratic politics is going to pull you
out of the country and then we'll come
right back in
and there and they're laughing at us
doing it they're they're not only
winning all of these battles they're
laughing at us while they do it why
i think the reason here
is that the taliban has a substantive
vision
for society i i don't think it's a
particularly great vision i think it's a
perverse vision but it has substance
they
in the taliban in this militant group
of ragtag people who i guess they're not
so ragtag now because they have all our
military equipment
they know what they want society to look
like and they have cohesion among their
group they've got buy-in on what they
all want society to look like
we in the west
do not
we don't have a substantive vision
certainly on the right we don't and we
don't have cohesion
okay all we do is sort of criticize or
we we deconstruct things on the left and
we debunk things on the right and we all
we're all engaging in critical thinking
or the the prevailing analytical lenses
are critical theory or a critical race
theory it's all about tearing things
down
the west in part failed in afghanistan
because we didn't know what we wanted to
do did we want to just kill osama bin
laden do we want to just kill some
terrorists do we want to nation build
did we want to hoist the pride flag did
we want to instill
1970s feminism in what what are we doing
do we want to stop china do we want to
stop russia is it there to check their
ambitions do we want an empire do we
want to just be a nation what are we
doing
the taliban knows what it's doing
if we want to effectively
offer a different an alternative for
society we need to know what that is we
need to know what we're doing
if you know what you're doing when
you're buying
auto parts then you're probably going to
rockauto.com so the other day i needed a
car part and what did i do you know what
i did i went to the brick and mortar
auto parts store so that i could answer
a million questions from the guy i don't
know the answers to most of them and i
got to wait for him to go in the back
not have the part go online probably to
rockauto.com order the part so that i
could wait a few more weeks and then pay
twice as much and i just felt that that
was the psych
i would never do that why would i do
that when there's rockauto.com
rockauto.com makes it so easy the
website is super easy to navigate
they've got all the parts for your car
or truck the prices are always reliably
low no gimmicks it's not like you got to
log in on tuesday afternoon to save 10
or whatever it's always reliably low
they're a family business serving auto
parts customers online for 20 years just
go to rockauto.com right now see all the
parts available for your car or truck
then write knowles cannon wlas in there
how did you hear about xbox so they know
that we sent you that is rockauto.com
to give you an example
of just how unserious we are in this
country
you've got
you've got the taliban overseas just
taking our equipment taking our air
bases calling the shots on this
evacuation and the west's sort of
floundering because our political
leaders don't know what they want to do
you've got
the the liberal establishment locking
down here in the united states so we're
now being told you the delta the delta
lambda phi beta kappa is spreading
you've all got to hunker down in your
homes for just another 15 years to slow
the spread we're being told you can't
you can't go outside you really you
should mask your kid up you should never
let your kids see anybody's face ever
again you got to stick everybody with a
bunch of experimental drugs you got to
lose your business you've got to give up
your way of life
meanwhile
there was a fundraiser apparently for
the d triple c this is the democratic
congressional campaign committee it was
in napa
and nancy pelosi was there giving an
address
there were at least 100 people by my
count in the video probably more
none of them wearing masks none of
they're just sitting out in napa they're
having a nice time these are democratic
donors some you know relatively small
dollars so much larger
no one not a single person at this event
wearing masks
except the servers
could you imagine sending
a worse message so pelosi no mask the
guests no mask
but all the little peasant workers all
of the people bringing me my shablee and
my chatunoof to pop
while they have to wear masks they're
filthy they're unclean
we can't let them but no but we we we do
not need to worry about that ourselves
mind you this is the political party
pushing the lockdowns this is the
political party
calling the governor of florida ron
death santas because he won't force
everyone
to wear the face coverings
starting to see some parallels here
between what's going on in afghanistan
what's going on a lot of insistence on
face coverings a lot of destruction of
traditional culture
i'm not saying they're comparable i'm
just saying there are strange
eerie similarities
and
rampant hypocrisy
that's what's because we're not a
serious country i was thinking about
this when i was on a flight recently
where they told us you're going to kill
everyone if you don't if you don't wear
the mask you got to wear the mask the
whole flight it's a nine-hour flight
doesn't matter keep it on at all times
while you're eating unless you want this
little warm cookie and then they put a
little cookie in front of you and you're
allowed to take your your mask down and
eat the delicious cookie but then
then you got to put the mask right back
up because it you're you're at risk of
dying or of killing other people
it's a it's such a serious risk that the
only way you can you can really
run that risk is if you want to eat a
warm delicious cookie it's just
capricious
it's just based on the whims of these
politicians
in whom
we do not have any credibility or we do
not have any trust anymore
think about what happened last year the
lockdowns
prevented a lot of elective surgeries
and even some not so elective surgeries
so when the hospital shut down when the
the doctor's offices went full
bore on covid
if you had a cancer surgery you're
supposed to get that would be pushed off
if you had plastic surgery just sort of
regular cosmetic surgery that would be
pushed off if you had your regular sort
of checkup type procedures that would be
pushed off all to focus on the wuhan
cough
so last year u.s health services overall
dropped one percent
even amid the covid stuff
overall health procedures dropped one
percent non-covid related services
obviously dropped much much more there
was one type of surgery though that
spiked last year
transgender surgery
transgender surgery
according to the american society of
plastic surgeons
spiked significantly and they're
focusing on just one type of plastics or
of of transgender plastic surgery which
is for young women who think that
they're men or who want to be men and
who are mutilating their bodies to look
more like men apparently young women
with gender dysphoria are having their
breasts removed
in order to seem
male in record numbers
those surgeries
rose 12 last year 12 from 14 602 in 2019
to 16 353
in 2020. this
number does not include
mastectomies surgeries and transgender
treatments done by other medical
professionals too this is only the ones
done by plastic surgeons but there are
other procedures that are done
by other doctors
it's not a serious country
that's first of all
that's not a country that really
believes that we need to put off all
elective surgeries until after covet
just like the party in napa is not a
gathering of people who really believe
the delta is super dangerous who really
believe the masks do anything who really
believe that we can't go out of our
homes if they really believe that they
just wouldn't go to the lunch and they
certainly would wear masks but they
don't really believe it they just want
you to believe it
they just it's just about the imposition
of the rule from the party that is
single-handedly just about pushing these
rules the same thing goes even among
these medical professionals we have to
shut down all of the elective surgery
except for the most delusional
unnecessary surgery of all namely the
one that mutilates perfectly healthy
organs to indulge a fashionable delusion
that is that runs contrary to reality
but it's but it's politically correct
it's probably the most politically
correct surgery and so now everyone gets
behind it
is it any wonder that our enemies are
mocking us
is it any meanwhile
here in the united states even in
generally red states the coronavirus
lockdown measures and the punishments
are increasing dramatically
even in some of the red states so as
rona cases rise up in mississippi the
state's department of health sent out an
alert saying that people who test
positive for coronavirus need to isolate
for ten days if they don't isolate for
ten days
they can face
a fine of up to five thousand dollars
and five years in prison
right now in
california for instance
if you don't disclose to your sexual
partner that you've got aids
you you won't be punished for that
you won't be punished
but if you
have the wuhan cough that for a lot of
people doesn't even present is
particularly serious for the vast
majority of people actually
you can go to prison for five years
is that a serious country it's not just
our country
it's over in australia
in australia right now australia makes
mississippi look like it's child's play
australia is so freaked out about the
spread of the rona
that
they
are you know telling people to take all
these precautions lock down don't go out
don't buy things
one animal shelter was so worried that
people would come adopt the rescue
dogs amid the surge of coronavirus
that they just shot all the dogs dead
they just
they just killed a bunch of puppies
to stop people from adopting the puppies
because if the people adopted the
puppies they would they would leave
their homes and interact with them
i'm not much of a dog person okay i
always consider myself a people person
not like a dog guy or a cat guy even i
know
that killing puppies
is pretty extreme and not not a great pr
look but that that's mass hysteria that
you're seeing
this is there was a woman
who tweeted yesterday
who
said this doesn't even relate exactly to
coronavirus only tangentially she
tweeted out and said that
she can no longer speak to her son that
she and her son always had a great
relationship but her son voted for
donald trump
and he's a conservative and she doesn't
even she doesn't understand him anymore
she doesn't even know him anymore and
she and i at first i thought this was
just a hoax but i'm beginning to think
it isn't a hoax there's this very long
tweet thread her saying i've been crying
for days and days but i had i just had
to cut him out of my life completely i
had to
because i can't because he voted for
trump and so he's bad and he's evil
but i miss i hate this this is terrible
it's really stop sending me mean tweets
people this is so awful
i i think this could be real i think
this is happening i think people are in
the grips
of a mass
hysteria
with their neurotic response to the
coronavirus with their neurotic response
to donald trump with their
neurotic with their neuroses generally
they
aren't i don't even i i don't mean this
as as if people all have these clinical
problems there's a social contagion
effect too
just as there is
such a
psychological condition as gender
dysphoria but there's a social contagion
whereby it spreads when people
accept these things the same is true for
neurosis the same is true for hysteria
people
are really
on edge why is that
because we don't have cohesion because
we don't have things that are settled
because we don't agree on anything we
don't even agree on the definition of
man and the definition of woman and so
when we've had this debate about afgh
this actually does relate back to
afghanistan we've had this debate should
we project power in afghanistan should
we pull back the simple fact is if you
don't have cohesion at home if you don't
know what you stand for what you're
doing you can't project
strength abroad even if you want to
ben today
is coincidental he must have been
listening to my show this morning
because his title is joe biden is not
competent in any sense he was either
listening to me or joe biden's own
secretary of state go check out ben's
show today also make sure you get the
reader's pass for four bucks a month the
daily wire readers pass unlocks
exclusive editorial content that unpacks
trending political and cultural topics
penned by everyone from candace owens to
dan crenshaw
to yours truly
when you sign up with readers pass you
also get access to the morning wire
newsletter a monday through saturday
email covering the top stories that you
need to know available only to daily
wire members all of this can be yours
for just four dollars a month act fast
because right now we are offering a one
month free trial head on over to
dailywire.com we'll be right back with a
lot more
we have a mass hysteria going through
not just the united states
just the anglosphere at least and and in
the west probably more broadly
we're not focusing on the real
challenges that we have as a country we
are inventing new challenges we are
indulging in delusions of victimization
while the taliban is taking all of our
weapons in afghanistan hundreds of
billions of dollars of weapons
we here in the west
are worried about
microaggressions against pantran
pseudo bi non-binary sexual whatever i
mean just completely fictitious
categories
in the united kingdom right now
this is this is a symbol of our broader
understanding of justice and how to run
a society
in the united kingdom they're retiring
old patrol cars all just regular
run-of-the-mill cop cars to keep peace
on the streets they are retiring them
and replacing them
with rainbow-colored
anti-hate crime cars
a police officer in the united kingdom
explains the move
the rainbow cars the hate crime cars
whatever we want to call them they are
part of our vehicle fleet so you know
we're always replacing vehicles they get
um all of the police sort of insignia
put on them as normal but there will
normally be then something added on that
is to do with the rainbow side of things
but they're out there as normal patrol
vehicles sometimes people will ask us
how can you afford to do that you know
that's not right to to spend money on
putting a rainbow on a car well actually
the cost is quite minimal but the
confidence that it can bring by just
having that rainbow on there and people
say to me you know the impact of seeing
the rainbow is so huge and the idea is
that the cars are there in the
communities generally on normal policing
patrol just again to show the community
that we want you to come forward if
something is happening that you know
isn't right then we absolutely want you
to come forward so it is there to try
and give confidence to our lgbt plus
community but also to other
underrepresented groups and unless we
have an organization where all of our
staff feel that they can feel included
that they that they are included um i
don't think we can deliver the best
service to our communities
now i know that that was in another
language that was in
uh british so i i would like to
translate that for you into american
dear taliban
dear china
please come invade us
please we are no longer a serious people
we do not understand anything about our
society or criminal justice or i'm
becoming a legislator freaking i don't
know my accent's not great this is
pathetic this is real this is like a
monty python sketch
this is
i want to be a woman you want to be a
woman i want to have babies this is
literally a monty python sketch
and now it is
police chiefs in the united kingdom
saying we're not going to focus on
real crime anymore
we're not going to focus on people you
know stabbing you
and taking your property so
then at the philosophical level we're
not going to focus on the protection of
private property we're not going to
focus on the protection of our political
order and our political tradition
instead
we're going to focus on
finding out whether or not anyone in the
community
has any
objection in their own mind or
conscience to men dressing up like women
and we're going to root that out because
transphobia
is not that's not what we're going to
stand for here in the united kingdom
look it's ridiculous in the uk that they
have rainbow colored police cars trying
to root out thought crimes among people
who
object to the idea that you know men
should be dancing around in stilettos
but we have the same sort of thing
happening here in the united states
we do
right right now
tony blair former uh prime minister of
of the uk
tony tony blair who was the prime
minister who brought his nation into the
war on terror he was pm while george
bush was the president
he was a representative of
the kind of neo-liberal consensus of the
1990s he was he was sort of the
equivalent of bill clinton but bill
clinton wasn't all that different from
george w bush it was all the same kind
of thing we're going to have really
rip-roaring economy at home
we're going to cut taxes a lot we're
going to cut some regulation but we're
going to project power overseas we're
going to project the kind of liberal
vision of society over on the middle
east
tony blair is furious
he said the decision to pull out of of
uh afghanistan
is imbecilic
and he wrote he wrote a 2700 word piece
on his website about this i will spare
you the piece but it's worth pointing
out his problems here because i think it
actually gets to the heart of what we're
all dealing with he says the world is
now uncertain of where the west stands
because it's so obvious that the
decision to withdraw from afghanistan in
this way was not driven by grand
strategy but by politics we didn't need
to do it we chose to do it we did it in
an obedience to an imbecilic political
slogan about ending the forever wars as
if our engagement in 2021 was remotely
comparable to our commitment 20 or even
10 years ago and in circumstances in
which troop numbers had declined to a
minimum and no allied soldier had lost
their life in combat in 18 months
the absence of across the aisle
consensus and collaboration and the deep
politicization of foreign policy and
security issues is visibly atrophying us
power
and for britain out of europe as uh for
britain out of europe and suffering the
end of the afghanistan mission by our
greatest ally with little or no
consultation we have serious reflection
to do
so he's also bringing up brexit here he
also didn't really like brexit so notice
what he's saying
first he calls out i think this is the
most important word he calls that the
politicization of foreign policy
now
it's got that word policy in it you know
from politics and he's saying it
shouldn't be politicized what he's
saying is that the people should have
really no say over foreign policy this
shouldn't be open to democratic debate
this should be done by the experts who
know
what liberalism stands for and they're
going to spread it around the world and
don't you dare
oppose it
he's saying that we pulled out of
afghanistan because of this imbecilic
political slogan about the forever wars
right this imbecillic democratic process
whereby the people
decided they they didn't want to be
there anymore
by the way in some ways following the
wisdom of the founding fathers virtually
all of whom warned explicitly against
continual warfare i'm thinking of james
madison i'm thinking of washington's
warnings about entangling alliances and
jefferson then invokes them too
he said imbecilic that we would allow
the people to make this decision
now
people don't know what the west stands
for
right tony that
that's the problem you're getting you've
identified the problem but you're
getting the order wrong
it's not that now we don't know what the
west stands for because we pulled out of
this godforsaken backwater in the middle
east
we pulled out of the god forsaken
backwater
and we bungled the political mission
there
because we don't know what the west
stands for
what is it what are we after this was
the this was the grave problem of the
1990s
the 1990s we had we won the cold war
at the turn of the 1990s the berlin wall
comes crumbling down the soviet union is
dismantled
largely because ronald reagan spent them
into oblivion
and so now
the united states leading the west
broadly is the superpower in the world
and there was i remember there was a
battle
at the 1992 convention the republican
convention who was going to be the
nominee was going to be george bush the
kind of liberal moderate
internationalist or was it going to be
pat buchanan who's this sort of a serbic
conservative culture warrior
and the rival speeches gave rival
visions of society george bush he barely
talked about the culture
already you had had political
correctness
woke-ism the proto-wochism
leftism rotting out the country since
the 1960s and george bush didn't want to
touch it he said forget the culture war
at home we've just got to win the peace
we've got to spread our markets overseas
we've got to trade with everybody we've
got to dominate the global economy
that's all that matters shoot up gdp
pat buchanan said no we've it was called
the cultural war speech we've got
a big culture war coming at home we are
going to be grappling with what the
relationship of the citizen is to the
state we're going to be grappling what
the nature with what the nature of man
is we're going to be
debating what marriage is we're going to
be debating who we are what we stand for
so we've got to we've got to figure out
those questions in order to effectively
project power abroad and obviously
george bush won the right ignored the
culture problems
for decades and now look where we are
and the same thing was true of the sort
of clinton democrats same thing was true
of tony blair and the neoliberals
everywhere they just they got the order
wrong they did they couldn't get their
own house in order and so they very
ineffectively projected power overseas
you're seeing this play out right now in
jamaica
in jamaica of all places
jamaica right now
there was a clip going around of a
protest outside of an american embassy
in jamaica
and what were they were they protesting
the decision to withdraw from
afghanistan
no were they protesting
the lack of concern for black lives and
the uh and george floyd know
they were protesting the fact that the
u.s embassy in jamaica was flying the
rainbow flag
and as you might be able to see in the
background the us embassy continues to
fly the lgbt flag lesbian gay bisexual
transgender flag
in breach of the vienna convention
articles 31e article 20 and article 41
right they are being hostile towards our
laws our culture and our own democratic
system instead of flying the jamaican
flag for eman's dependence they have
decided to fly that flag and that is an
insult to our country
a lot of
liberals in america are going to be very
confused by this clip
well no but no you're you don't you're
but you're black you're
from a small island nation you're no
you're
you're supposed you're on our side
you're not what you huh you don't
totally go along with the latest
liberal fashions and ideas no
because the rainbow flag
is not primarily a symbol of
being nice to homosexuals
it's not primarily a symbol of being
nice to people who
you know men who think that they're
women it's not primarily a symbol of
kindness or charity
it is a symbol of imperial hegemony
that's why it's being flown at the u.s
embassy that's why the united states
flies it at embassies all around the
world
including in kabul wow can you can you
wonder why we lost the country and you
wonder what
it is a symbol the reason it's a symbol
is because the lgbt flag
now they've expanded it even more it's
the progress flag so it includes all
this other racial and sexual stuff
regardless of of what it includes
it is
a symbol not of
a nation
not of a particular people not of a
particular place
it's a symbol
of allegedly universal values
the meaning of the lgbt rainbow flag
would be the same in jamaica as it is in
the united states would be the same in
timbuktu as it is in the united states
whereas the symbol of the stars and
stripes would not be the stars and
stripes the american flag is a symbol of
the american nation it refers to a
particular place in particular people
but the lgbt the rainbow flag that's for
everyone the blm flag does this to to
some degree as well
and so we fly it as the symbol of our
empire but not everybody likes our
empire
not everybody abroad the jamaicans who
are protesting
don't support
men becoming women as their
as their raison d'etre you know as
they're sort of as their as the beating
heart of their nation they actually
don't approve of it
and i would say probably most other
countries around the world don't approve
of it or just don't think of it very
much it's not what animates them as a
people
and frankly a lot of people in the
united states
don't believe that that flag represents
them either
probably most people don't feel that
that flag represents them
and so you've got
this this what i think is
kind of a secondary debate
do we project power overseas do we have
an american empire do we hold
territories do we hold firm and pre what
american power what america what are we
standing for
if if the by the american empire we mean
flying the rainbow flag everywhere and
defending the right of men to become
women by mutilating themselves in
cosmetic surgery then i don't want to
project that power
that would be bad to project that if if
american power means projecting
christendom you know and and the values
that traditionally have animated our
culture then yeah i'd like to project
that but you've got to decide what
exactly
it is that we're doing this is this is
what gives me a little sympathy for joe
biden
he he has blown this thing as much as
you possibly can i mean he has bungled
the he is he has withdrawn from
afghanistan in the most incompetent way
possible but the problem is a lot bigger
than joe biden
joe biden this was some days ago now
he's somewhat changing his tune but you
know his tune changes by the hour
because he doesn't know what end is up
joe biden in a very testy interview on
abc
defended his himself because he said
there was no non-chaotic way to get out
of afghanistan
when you had
the government of afghanistan
the leader of that government getting
into a plane and taking off and going
another country
when you saw
the significant collapse of the top of
the uh afghan troops we had trained or
up to 300 000 of them just leaving their
equipment and and taking off
that was you know i'm not this is that
that's what happened that's simply what
happened but we've all seen the pictures
we've seen those hundreds of people
packed into a c-17 we've seen
afghans following us four days ago five
days ago what did you think when you
first saw those pictures what i thought
was weird we have to gain control of
this so you don't think this could have
been handled this actually could have
been handled
better in any way no mistakes
no i i don't think it could have been
handled in a way that
so that clip was four or five days ago
it was i didn't want to miss it i wanted
to get to it
uh because it's one just the snapping it
shows you things really are not working
out the way that the the blob the
liberal establishment had
thought that they would
you know
joe biden didn't campaign for president
we now forget that he didn't campaign
every the whole blob just protected him
the whole time but now they're not
protecting him now there's a little
discord even among the liberal
establishment
he's sticking by his story though there
was no non-chaotic way to pull out
he's probably right about that
there were better ways than this that's
for sure
you didn't need to leave hundreds of
millions hundreds of billions of dollars
worth of equipment and thousands of
americans and you didn't you didn't need
to lose bagram air base you didn't i
mean you there
it could have it could have been handled
better
but but the broader problem is bigger
than joe biden
joe biden right now he's going to just
be focused on trying to cling to
whatever power and approval he's got a
reporter just confronted him at a at a
press briefing
asked him about a public opinion poll
that shows that most people no longer
think the man is competent a new poll
out today shows americans wanted to
withdraw from afghanistan
but they disapprove of the way you've
handled it poll also found it based in
part in what's transpired in the last
week a majority of americans
and forgive me i'm just the messenger no
longer consider you to be competent
focused or effective in the job i
haven't seen that poll
it's out there
from cbs this morning
what would you say to those americans
who no longer believe that you look to
the job
i had a basic decision to make
i either withdraw
america from a 20-year war
that depending whose analysis you accept
cost us 150 million dollars a day for 20
years or 300 million dollars a day for
20 years
all right end the war
and i decided to end the war
so
biden
reacted with his
most frequently used
political tool which is to laugh at the
reporter or to laugh at the opponent
you'll remember he did this during the
vice presidential debates with paul ryan
when romney was running in 2012 anything
ryan would say most of which was true
joe biden just laughed
with a big you know the big joe bien
biden teeth those gigantic artificial
teeth and he would just laugh it off and
shrug it and let it go so that's what's
happening here the reporter
who is
presumably on his side or at least
sympathetic to it is saying hey
uh
most people don't think you're con i'm
sorry don't shoot the messenger i don't
i hate to say this to you but most
people don't think you're competent
and then he just keeps going back to i
think in a way that's actually pretty
smart to his most defensible position
which is he's trying to make it about
should we have pulled out should we not
have pulled out but that's not the
debate that isn't the debate the
majority of americans said we should
pull out
the debate is how should we have pulled
out could this have been handled better
i think everyone believes it could have
been handled much much much better
but joe biden doesn't want to answer for
his gross incompetence because that
would that would put the debate on the
wrong wrong side of things the defense
secretary
right now refuses to state how he
advised joe biden not just on whether or
not to withdraw but how he could
withdraw defense secretary was asked
this on abc
he
he knows it's a poisonous political
issue and so
he's got no comment
did you want to see
a small force remain in afghanistan
martha and you know i'm not going to
tell you what uh what my recommendation
to our to our president was uh i would
just tell you that uh
that like
uh everyone else uh the president uh
listened to our our our input uh
again he conducted a very rigorous
and thoughtful process and he made a
decision and i support that decision
and at the end of the day the president
made his decision and he wouldn't say
obviously which one he was leaning
toward the reporters are still going
after them
you know
you know it's bad when the reporters are
going after the elected democrats there
was a reporter who asked a pentagon
spokesman said how did you get this so
wrong and he didn't really have an
answer for that but i do have an answer
for that i know how they got this so
wrong and it's not
it's not just having to do with you know
this air base or that that embassy or we
had to pull out at this day and the
taliban made this deal in the previous
administration and
the reason we got this so wrong is one
politics is not just about singers it's
not just about one-liners in debates and
on and on twitter even or you know much
as i love good zingers on twitter there
is a basic competency that you need to
have and many of the people staffing not
just the
elected side but the
the state department the defense
department the the
bureaucracy side a lot of them are don't
have even basic competence
that's gone now and
the other way we got this so wrong is we
can't answer the most fundamental
questions about our country what are we
here for what do we stand for who are
the american people what is the american
nation where is the american border
what is the difference between a man and
a woman
if we can't answer those basic questions
about who we are what we stand for then
we are never going to know what we're
doing
and
what we're doing in our specific job or
what we're doing as a matter of grand
strategy you've got to answer the basic
questions first i'm michael nolsas the
michael knowles show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
bora our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by nika geneva michael
knowles show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 on the matte
wall show we talk about the things that
matter real issues that affect you your
family our country not just politics but
culture faith current events all the
fundamentals if they matter to you come
check out the show